jeanne moreau de passage à paris entre
les deux films qu'elle tourne
actuellement avec tony richardson nous a
parlé de mademoiselle le rôle qu'elle
incarne dans le premier de ces films
personnage de mademoiselle c'est un
personnage très complexe malfaisants
maléfique mais qui trouve son bonheur et
son équilibre en faisant du mal aux
autres
elle est pas tellement triste et man was
elle met le cinéma est-il votre seule
raison de vivre pas le cinéma
être actrice être comédienne et le
théâtre vous y pensez de temps en temps
mais maintenant je commence à y penser
et je vais faire du théâtre en 1966 on
est en 1965 en 1966 je ferai mes débuts
à au théâtre à londres
j'espère en octobre dans un nom alors
vous quittez paris vous habitez la côte
d'azur et vous kiffez pôle théâtre
également paris vous avez une dent
contre paris absolument pas non et c'est
simplement parce que c'est une
proposition que je trouve merveilleuse
peter brook qui m'a déjà dirigé à paris
dans la chatte sur un toit brûlant veut
monter un londres avec moi la pièce de
shakespeare antoine et cléopâtre pour
une série de représentations
alors comme j'ai très peur de
recommencer au théâtre je vais passer ma
peur à londres et puis après je viendrai
jouer une autre pièce à paris on ne dit
plus aujourd'hui jeanne moreau ont dit
la mort ok ce que ça vous fait au moins
déjà mais ça on lit partout dans tous
les mois je n'ai pas les journaux mais à
moi me dis pas ça mais votre légende ça
ne vous effraie pas un peu c'était ma
légende du pain tarn la vérifier
beaucoup parce que je travaille beaucoup
et puis quand je ne travaille pas je
suis dans ma maison avec ma famille et
mes amis
alors mes rapports avec les gens n'ont
pas
quel sentiment avez-vous lorsqu'on vous
gratifie du du plus voluptueux animal
dramatique de ce temps jyp aller et
lorsque l'on dit que ça c'est dans la
revue prestigieuse et non moins sérieuse
qui s'appelle times que greta garbo
n'existe pas auprès de vous à ça je
trouve qu'on exagère parce que j'aime
pas beaucoup qu'on peut dire du bien de
quelqu'un on détourne essaye de détruire
la personnalité de quelqu'un d'autre
vous aurait déclaré une jeune que vous
aimiez quitter les choses du genre quand
on vous parle je pense que dans la vie
il ya des cycles et qu'on est entraînée
par les événements et tout d'un coup du
jour au lendemain on se retrouve entouré
de gens totalement différent et
maintenant une vie qui est relié à la
précédente mais qui est différente elle
aussi mais au fur et à mesure que je
vous réponde je pense que j'ai dû dire
ça à une époque où l'amitié n'avait pas
une très grande place dans ma vie ça ne
bougeait pas le temps de me consacrer
mais maintenant je ne m'imagine pas
vivants sont mes amis
alors même si je pars très loin ou même
si ma vie est différente
je ne vois pas sans eux dernière
question jeunes êtes vous heureuse
oui je suis très heureuse avec
quelquefois l'impression de n'être pas
et quand ça m'arrive bien je m'engueule
parce que j'ai pas le droit de ne pas
être heureuse